- HO HO HO.
- WHOO!
- OH, MY GOSH.
- HO.
- WE'RE DOING IT, GUYS.
WE'RE OFFICIALLY
DOING ROAD RULES, MAN.
- MM-HMM. YEAH.
- [laughs] THIS IS GREAT.
- DO YOU GUYS KNOW WHAT
THIS THING DOES TO PANTIES?
SOPS THEM, THEN DROPS THEM.
- YES, IT DOES.
- YEAH, CHICKS LOVE DUDES
WITH RVs.
MY UNCLE DRIVES ONE.
GETS LAID ALL THE TIME.
- YEAH?
- HE'S A COKE DEALER ALSO,
SO THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT.
- IT'S PROBABLY WHAT HE DID
TO BUY THE RV, YOU KNOW?
- AND I WANT THE BEST BED
'CAUSE I'M PROBABLY
GONNA BE DOING SOME "FUGZIN'."
- WELL, WE ALL WANT THAT.
- YOU BETTER BE.
- YEAH. BUT WHOEVER TOUCHES
THE RV FIRST GETS IT.
- WAIT--NO. WHAT?
- [laughs] OH! YOU SUCKERS.
- DAMN IT, ADAM.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE US A LITTLE BIT
OF ADVANCE NOTICE.
WHOEVER TOUCHES THE OTHER SIDE,
GETS TO CONTROL THE RADIO.
READY, SET, GO.
- WAIT, NO--
- I SAID READY, SET, GO.
[laughing]
YEAH.
[water running]
UH, HEY, MONTEZ.
WE'RE JUST GONNA TAKE A TOUR
OF THE RV IF THAT'S COOL.
- YOU WANT ME TO TAKE
YOUR GARBA--OKAY.
YOU HAVE A BAG FULL
OF DOUBLE-ENDED DILDOS?
- THAT'S USED.
THAT'S WAS USED PROBABLY.
- STRAP-ONS--
IS THIS EVAN STONE?
- WHAT'S HE'S DOING BACK THERE?
- IS THAT EVAN STONE?
HE'S MY FAVORITE.
- MAN, THAT'S $1,200 WORTH
OF PREMIUM SEX TOYS.
GOT THEM FOR COLLEEN
FOR OUR TEN-YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
MADE HER A MUSIC VIDEO,
BUT IT'S ALL OVER, MAN!
IT'S OVER!
- WHY IS THAT?
- 'CAUSE SHE CHEATING ON ME,
MAN!
- WHOA.
- WAIT.
- DID SHE--SHE--
DID SHE TELL YOU THAT?
UM, BUT SHE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT, LIKE, WHO IT MIGHT BE
OR, LIKE, WHAT THE PERSON
LOOKS LIKE, RIGHT?
- MAN, I HEARD HER ON THE PHONE
TALKING ABOUT
SHE WORRIED ABOUT GETTIN' A STD.
LIKE SHE GOT SOME KIND OF THING
CALLED COOCHIE MOLD.
- WHAT?
- AWESOME, DUDE.
I ACTUALLY JUST WON A FOOT RACE,
SO I'M ENTITLED TO THE BEST BED.
SO IS THAT IN THE FRONT?
- HEY, YOU CAN'T USE THIS
ANYMORE, DUMMY.
I'M LIVING IN THERE.
- OKAY, FOR SURE.
- LIKE, WHAT THE [bleep]
HAPPENED TO MY LIFE?
I HAD IT ALL.
TELL YOU WHAT, MAN,
IF I CATCH THIS DUDE,
I'M GONNA CUT HIS DICK OFF.
I'M JUST GONNA TAKE IT
AND JUST RIP IT.
I'LL PUT IT IN A MICROWAVE
AND COOK IT.
- OH, RIGHT.
YEAH, 'CAUSE, LIKE, CHEATERS.
WE HATE 'EM.
THEY MAKE ME SICK.
BUT YOU KNOW,
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TREAT 'EM NICE.
I'M GONNA GO, UH, THROW UP
'CAUSE I'M SO SICK
OF HEARING ABOUT
YOUR HORRIBLE SITUATION, MAN.